AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER
AS THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE VIEWING
US FROM AFAR CAN TELL THIS IS
AN UNUSUAL PROCEEDING AT LEAST
IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF OUR
SETTING WERE ACTUALLY ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE- IN
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF- WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS A
CENTER WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN TO. ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN
THE PER. AND ARE. WELL THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORKS
WHICH TO TESTIFIED TODAY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A
MOMENT SO IF YOU'RE PREPARING
TO CALL IN. ANNOUNCER SO YOU
CAN TAKE IT DOWN. TO THE
DISCIPLINE. IS EIGHT FOUR. TO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO ZERO ONE
SIX TWO SIX SIX. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT THE MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY.
OPEN YOUR LINE AND THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING- THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE SO IN OTHER WORDS IF
YOU'RE WATCHING ON COMPUTER.
BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY SO. WE NEED
TO TURN OFF. THE UP THE VOLUME
HE TO MUTE YOUR COMPUTER IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HERE IS A
SUMMARY IN ANY OF THE- TO OUR
THIS IS THE MEDIAN. FROM THE
PROMOTE. FOR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS OF MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT IS BEING MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND GET DOCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING THE USE OR THE NEW
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RISK ONE PAYS SOLAR
PLANTS THE PARTIES. TODAY'S
AGENDA WE HAVE ONLY ONE MATTER
THAT'S A CA SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY- BEFORE WE HEAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARTES
PRESENTATION THE BILL LET'S
DALY SHOULD QUORUM SO MISTER
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL ALL. HERE NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG LEYVA. STERN. ALL
RIGHT WELL WE HAVE A QUORUM ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE
AUTHOR BUT BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE AUTHOR- I WANT TO LET THE
CALLERS REPORTING TO CALLERS
KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
MANY PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY AS
POSSIBLE. HE OF THOSE IN
SUPPORT ONE WITNESS WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES IN SUPPORT
ANOTHER PRIMARY WITNESS IN UP
TO WILL ALSO HAVE THREE
MINUTES. CALLERS CALL IN BE
PERMITTED TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN SUPPORT WE ASSUME
YOU'RE SUPPORTING YOUR CALLING
UP. WE ASSUME YOU'RE OPPOSING.
NUMBER CALLERS WE MAY HAVE TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF CALLERS IT
MAY CALL IN- WILL JUST IS AS IS
NECESSARY- LATER ON. ALL RIGHT
SO LET'S SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. HE THOUGHT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS LITERALLY YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH ME IN THE
COALITION FOR OVER A YEAR TO
BRING THIS MEASURE HI TO YOUR
COMMITTEE TODAY THIS MEASURE IS
NOT ABOUT US BUT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVING THE RIGHT. ON
ALTHOUGH A CA SIX ABOUT. VOTING
RIGHTS FOR THOSE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED THIS IS A PRIOR
THE BILL OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
WHENEVER JUSTICE. AND THIS
WOULD ESSENTIALLY RIGHT OR
WRONG HERE IN CALIFORNIA BY THE
U. S. AS WE KNOW IS THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD AS FAR AS ACCURACY IN
VOTING. HOWEVER OUR ROADS
DEMOCRACY HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT
EASY. FOR RACIALLY BASED POLL
TAXES TO EXCLUDING WOMEN WE'VE
HAD TO FIGHT FOR VOTING JUSTICE
FOR OVER ONE HUNDRED YEARS. NO
THE MEDICARE'S ARE ESPECIALLY
OF THE RELIC SEVEN JIM CROW
SYSTEM LOOKING TO. EXCLUDE
PEOPLE FROM CAL. AND JUST THE
CAL HISTORY LESSON IN THE LATE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. WE ACTUALLY
IN THE STATE CONSTITUTION HAD
IN WRITING. LANGUAGE THAT WE
SPENT RESTRICTEDINDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE IN THE SAME MENTALLY
DEFICIENT FOR CONVICTS FROM
VOTING IN CALIFORNIA. ABOUT A
HUNDRED YEARS LATER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. FOR YEARS BEFORE
YOU CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY
SENATOR THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA TRY TO LOOSEN UP
THESE POLICIES A LITTLE BIT
FRANKLY THAT WAS A BIG
PROGRESSIVE STEP AT THE TIME.
BUT THEY REACHED. INDIVIDUALS
ON PAROLE VOTING AND
DEFENSIVELY TAKES EFFECT THANKS
TO ATTEND TO RIGHT THAT WRONG.
WE KNOW THE FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ON PAROLE OUR NEIGHBORS
ARE COLLEAGUES THEY WORK THEY
PAY TAXES AND DEATH AND ALL.
PAROLE IN PENAL CODE IS TRYING
TO HELP REINTEGRATE PEOPLE BACK
INTO SOCIETY. THE RESTRICTING
VOTING RIGHTS IS A FORM OF
PUNISHMENT AND GOES IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION. TODAY MORE
THAN EVER WE'RE TAKING A HOT
PASSAGE PERSONALIZED PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIS IS NOT A
RED ISSUE RED STATUS YOU'RE A
BLUE STATE ISSUE. DOZENS OF
STATES REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT
STATES HAVE DONE THIS ALREADY
THIS WILL ALLOW THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO WEIGH IN IN
NOVEMBER OF THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. HE AND I HAVE ONE WITH.
IN THE- YOU TO TESTIFY I'M NOT
THEIR THEIR NAME BELIEVE THEIR
THEIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
MCCARTY AND I KNOW YOU'VE
WORKED LONG AND HARD AND
DILIGENTLY IN NEW FORMED AN
INCREDIBLE COALITION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MATTER SO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK I UNDERSTAND
IT HEAT THE ANTI RISK.
COALITION IS THE PRIMARY WITH.
MISTER WILL BE GIVEN THREE S.
AND THEN AN OPPOSITE AND- AND
ALSO MY INGRAM. SO YOU WILL BE
ALSO AVAILABLE AND PROTECT THEM
XIN SHOULD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE REQUESTED. SO TO
KEEP BOTHERING MISTER THE FINAL
LINE. I DON'T HAVE A MOMENT HI.
I'M ON THE LINE ALL RIGHT OF
MEN OF MY READER IF YOU WOULD
ALLOW MISTER KEITH CHRISSY.
DISTRIBUTOR HI MY NAME IS GERRY
KEITH AND I'M CURRENTLY A
STUDENT AND A MASTER OF
DIVINITY PROGRAM AT FULLER
THEOLOGICAL SEMINARY AND A FULL
TIME I THOUGHT THAT. INVOLVED
IN MY LOCAL CHURCH. REPORTER
FOR MULTIPLE INITIATIVE AIMED
AT MAKING A POSITIVE DIFFERENCE
IN IN OUR COMMUNITY- I ALSO AM
A YOUTH MENTOR FOR YOU CAN ON
THE HARSH REALITY CALORIE. I
LOVE AND SUPPORT. THE OUR PRIME
RIB FROM SUPPORTING MY
COMMUNITY AT THE BALLOT BOX. AS
I AM ALSO ON MY CURRENT ROLE
YOU KNOW WHEN THE BOARD A FULL
HEARING APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE TOLD ME
NO LONGER CONSIDERED A PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND I WAS FREE TO CALL
HOME I WANTED TO START. IN TO
GIVE AS A FULL TIME LIKE THOSE
WORK UNDER THE PEOPLE NAVIGATOR
ENTRY I KNOW THAT I'M NOT THE
ONLY PERSON WHO BUILT THIS WAY.
THAT WHAT PEOPLE ON HOLD. OUR
NEIGHBORS ARE COLLEAGUES
FRIENDS WE'RE WORKING RAISING
FAMILIES PAYING TAXES WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION MANY PEOPLE WHO
I CODES ARE NOW YOU CAN TO
WORKERS. HI DALY TO GIVE US ACT
THAT THE BASIC NEEDS WE HAVE
WHILE MOST OF US ARE WORK FROM
HOME DURING THIS PANDEMIC
OTHERS ARE WORKING AT THE-
TRAINING CENTER FIRE. THANK YOU
NORTH STATE BARS AND WE CARED
ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY THAT'S WHY
WE DO THIS THE STATE OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD ONLY FOOLS AND
PARKS. LIKE IT WAS BEING SAID
COLD NINE CAN BE CONTINUATION
SOMEONE IN NEED OF SUPPORT AS
PRISON TERM AND THEN WE-
DECIDED TO RESUME ROLE THAT.
THERE'S MOTHER AND TAKE UP ALL
THAT ONLY. LOUISE MENTORED AND
LEADERS WHEN PEOPLE. FEEL THAT
THEY HAVE RESPONSE TO THE
COMMUNITY AND THEIR THEIR NEEDS
AND CONCERNS ADDRESS RECIDIVISM
DECLINE. VOTING IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT OF
CITIZENSHIP ANY COLLECTION IN
WHICH SOMEONE LIVING IN OUR
COMMUNITY IS IN WELCOME. IF
IT'S A MISSED OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE PARTY'S OF OUR STATE AND
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT MORE
CONSTITUENTS.  ACTUALLY- HAD
HE HE THE PLACE ISSUE ON THE
BACK GIVING HELLO. UNITY TO
RESTORE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE PAROLE IN FULLY
WELL. BACK I THINK YOU'RE READY
MA'AM. OF OUR COMMUNITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER KEITH
WELL WE'RE NOT GOING TO TURN TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES BUT BEFORE WE
DO- I SHOULD LET FOLKS KNOW
THAT THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AS I MENTIONED A LITTLE
WHILE AGO SPENT. ON A TIME OF
ON THIS I MET A- GROUPS IN
COLLEGE. AND IT IS MY VIEW THAT
ONCE YOU HAVE PAID THE PRICE
THAT YOU SHOULD BE RESTORED TO
ALL YOUR CIVIL RIGHTS INCLUDING
THE RIGHT TO VOTE. I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE. AND
I'VE ALSO- THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND IT IS MY VIEW
THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT. NUMBER
OF MEMBERS NUMBERS THERE'S
VOTING I'D IT THIS WILL PASS
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. TO THE
FLOOR- SO HAVING SAID NOW LET'S
TURN TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO
SEE IF THERE'S A ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISHES THE
TEST. IT LOOKS LIKE THERE IS NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY- ALL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THOSE WHO- WISH TO TESTIFY
VIA. CONFERENCE MODERATE REVIEW
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WE
NEED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT LET
ME UNDERLINE THIS IN SUPPORT OF
AB CA SIX. THEN WE WILL BEGIN.
MADAM MODERATELY I'M SORRY MY
APOLOGIES I REQUEST TO SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LIKE IF YOU LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THE-
BUREAU AT THIS TIME. TO OPEN
THE LINE OF LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT LET ME
LET ME JUST REITERATE THAT
THOSE IN SUPPORT SHOULD.
PROVIDE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND- IF THEY LIKE
SAY THEY'RE IN SUPPORT WE
ASSUME THERE IN SUPPORT. SO GO
AHEAD. AFTER THE GENITAL
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT OPEN LINES THREE YOUR MIND
IN OPEN. HI THIS IS PUT OUT AN
ISSUE AGE IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
KINGS. THANK YOU. OPEN LINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
TOMORROW'S LEGAL MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT OPEN LINE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS ERIC GENTRY FROM THE
RIDE PROGRAM AT YOUR BOW
COLLEGE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ACA SEEKS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT OPEN
LINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS MADE
USING YOUR ALSO FROM THE LEGAL
OWNER. OF AN INTERNET CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
THANK FELL. YOU AND NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRIS LIKE HE DOES ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI AND BOARD OF THE
PROVIDERS OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT OF. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN MY NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. CAN YOU MARK WE HAVE
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY
THERE I'M HOW LONG DO WE HAVE
TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMENTS. THAT
YOU JUST YOUR NAME IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION. GOT IT THANK YOU
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH LIVE JOHN
AND I AM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
TURN ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND WE ARE
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND MY NUMBER EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I BELIEVE
THAT YOU ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX. THANK
YOU. TO OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
BOYD WITH AN ISSUE JUSTICE AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AN EASY
SIX. THANK YOU. AND NEXT OPEN
LINE NUMBER NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FLIGHT NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
RIGHT SORRY THIS IS KAELIN
BEING WITH THE A LINE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY LINK
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO DO THE ANTHONY
GIVE MARTINO WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB CA SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS THAT'S FUNDING YES THEY
POLICY DIRECTOR PROTECTED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A HUGE SIX
THANK. THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
MINISTER FOR SMART TO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI DID YOU WONDER NEVER
READY WITH INITIATE JUSTICE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
SIX. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS
IS QUITTING GIPSON WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE CURRENTLY ON
PAROLE I STRONGLY SUPPORT A
SIX. THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE BELOW
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SECURE
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEES WORK ON THIS. THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. BUSINESS HERE
SPEAKING I'M ABOUT ALLIES CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU. LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS A LITTLE WHAT CALIFORNIA
INTEREST EUROPEAN JUSTICE
HEARING STRONG SUPPORT. YOU.
FLIGHT AT TO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY NAME IS CALDERON THE
POLICY DIRECTOR LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PERSONS OF CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US AND NONE WE ARE CO
SPONSOR THEN YOU'RE DEFINITELY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. GIVE. NINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY NAME IS JESSICA
HERNANDEZ FROM ORANGE COUNTY
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS KATE
CAMPBELL FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALLING THAT ALL OF US ARE NINE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS SAVANNAH MEAT IS A
MEMBER OF AN ISSUE JUSTICE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. CHAIR NUMBER
SOMEHOW THAT WOULD ON WHAT THE
WIDENING GROUP REPLICA A NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA AND CHANGE FOR
JUSTICE AT THE PORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY THREE YEAR LATE IS
NOW OPEN. YEAHMY NAME IS
CAPTAIN AT RADCLIFFE I AM A
MEMBER OF INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND EASY THEY
BEGIN THANK YOU. EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. KIND OF
FEELING- ON BEHALF OF VOTING
RIGHTS. FOR THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MIKE TO
LOCATE THE MEMBER AND DIDN'T
YOU DELAY UNDERGROUND SCHOLARLY
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY NAME IS HANNAH FROM
CARLA CALIFORNIA HI I'M CALLING
WITH ALL OF US ARE NONE CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FINALLY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS MIGUEL GARCIA FROM THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
SACRAMENTO AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JEFF NOR
PROFESSOR OF ENGLISH WITH
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGES WE
EMERGING SCHOLARS PROGRAM AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
SEX YOU. NINE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS
DONNA BUT ONLY WITH INITIATE TO
THE TRUMP THE COURT OF EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MY NAME ONLY THE CHICKEN WITH
THE ENTIRE RECIDIVISM COALITION
INSTRUCTOR PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I I'M CALLING
FOR ANY OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT RIGHT. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MARK
AND I WOULD INITIATE JACKSON IN
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD DAY THIS OF
LANDING CROWDY LIVE ALL OF US
CAN NON LEGAL PERMITTED FOR
PRINTERS WITH CHILDREN IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR IT A SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN
MY NUMBER SEVENTY YEAR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MEMBERS LEAGUE BYNUM UNITED
MESSICK WORKERS ASKED ME THIRTY
NINE THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AJ SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI KATHY WITH INITIATE
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS TONYA TONYA
FAN I'M WITH MERCURY FOUND WORK
BASED IN OAKLAND FRED NOW
BANNED BERNIE DINO BLOCKING
ANGELES AND WE WORK WITH TRIED
TO CALIFORNIA AND CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT
THAT. THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CLEAR LEVIN- I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OR CALLING
WITH ALL OF US ARE NONE AND I'M
CALLING IS STRONG SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I WAS VERY APPROVED
NUMBER OF INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I MEAN WE HAVE IS-
WITHIN THE HE DOES TO THE
CRACKER PROUD COSPONSORED EIGHT
EIGHT. REPORTER THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GIVE HIM THE CLAREMONT COLLEGES
THEIR NOMINATION COLLECTIVE I
AM CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE FEET. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE ONE OH FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S ANDRE
FROM LA COUNTY AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF IT THANKS.
THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS POLLY MANEUVERING I'M
CALLING WITH ALL OF US NINE
OAKLAND WHICH HAPPENED
BAKERSFIELD LA ORANGE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO SEVENTY
NINE SAN DIEGO. ALL OF WHICH
ARE KNOWN TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
ACA FOLKS THANK YOU. ONE TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AB ONE EDWARDS AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF STARTING
OVER ANYTHING RIVERSIDE ALL BUT
THEY'RE NON IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF EACH YEAR. THANK
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SASHA FELT THEME AS AN
INDIVIDUAL AS IF YOU AS A
STRONG VOLUNTEER AND SUPPORTER
OF INITIATE GOT THAT STRONGLY
SUPPORT FEEDBACK. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JULIA ROUTE FROM CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT SEC THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT NOT RESPONSIBLE TO LINE ONE
FOURTEEN YEAR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO YOUR HONOR. THANK YOU YES.
OKAY SORRY WHAT THAT THE
PERMANENT RECORD FROM CALLING
IN FROM ONTARIO CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS RASHEED ON ONE POINT
TWO U. JUSTICE ARM A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL WANTS
TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA SIX. THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE OPEN LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX AS A REMINDER IF
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THIS TIME. WHAT I
WANT TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR FOR CHILD
DISABILITY LIKE TO CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NINETY
FIVE YEAR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BY
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
META MODERATE IF WE MOVE ON.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NOT A
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. YES
SIR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NEXT
OPEN LINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN.
THE BOTTOM LINE
SIXTY NINE AND SUPPORT. GREAT
THANK YOUNG WOMAN WHO HAD
CENTER STATEWIDE COORDINATOR
BUT IS THIS THE WORKING
COLLECTION OUT COPELAND VERY
STRONG WORK AND EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU. ACTUAL CHANNEL LINE
ONE EIGHTEEN AND SUPPORT. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES THE
INTERIOR MY NAME IS TO BE QUICK
BETH AND I'M CALLING FROM LA
COUNTY WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
AND I AM A STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO TIMELINE I AM TWENTY
EIGHT AND SUPPORT. THE NEXT
LEVEL TIMELINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
IN SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BAILEY RIGHT FROM AN
ISSUE JUST AND STRONG BLACK
LIVES MATTER AT. I AM
RESPONSIBLE. THANK YOU. NOT A
LOT TIMELINE ONE OH SIX IN
SUPPORT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS A LETTER THAT HE GETS
FROM A MEMBER OF INITIATOR AND
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT A LOT TO A LOT ONE TWELVE
IN SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS MIKE
HERE PRINT AND I AM WRONG
REPORT OF A THREE DAY AND A
MEMBER AT LISTEN TO. THANK YOU.
HELLO TELL LINE AT ONE TEN AND
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS LEO
WEAVER I'M A MEMBER OF AN ISSUE
JUSTICE AND I THINK THE
TOURNAMENT ON STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU. AN
ACTUAL I KNOW ONE TWO EIGHT AND-
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE GOT A
NEW I AM WITH INITIATE THIS I
AM A STRONG. FOR EIGHT THANK
ALTHOUGH I THINK WE PART OF
BOATING AND VERY CRITICAL TO
HAVE PEOPLE WE INTEGRATE THE
FACT THAT WE THANK YOU. WHAT
HAD THE REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE CALL CREDIT THE
WIND AND THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN YOUR OWN NOW.
BETTER FIVE BUT MY ANGER AND CO
SPONSOR UNSTRUNG WITH EIGHT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ENACT
THE LAW TO LINE NINE TWENTY
SORRY LINE NINETY FIVE IN
SUPPORT. LINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
ALL RIGHT NEXT TO A HOTEL LINE
ONE TWENTY ONE AND SUPPORT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THE LATE
SHOW THREE FROM PEOPLE
OBJECTIVE AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT. YOU. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. AT THE MOMENT THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR- WITHIN A
MODEL WE'RE GONNA TURNED
OPPOSITION AND THE SAME. RULES
OF. THE OPPOSITION IS APPLIED
TO. PORT WILL FIRST HEAR FROM A
PRIMARY WITNESS ALTHOUGH I'VE
NOT HAD A PRIMARY WITNESS
IDENTIFIED BUT THAT- IF THERE
IS A PRIMARY WITNESS ON THE
PHONE HE OR SHE SHOULD AND IF I
AM CELLS THEN WILL BE PROVIDED
FOR. THE B. FIVE THREE THAT'S
BEEN- THOSE WHO WISH TO CALL IN
OPPOSITION- IT'S THE EXACT SAME
IT FOR SUPPORT YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANISED IN A AS SOON. IN
OPPOSITION OF ON THE OPPOSITION
LINE NO MATTER. AS A PRIMARY IN
OPPOSITION WE COULD TURN TO
THAT. NOW. ERR ERR ON THE LINE
YOU CAN PRESS. BETTER THAN
THEIR OWN WE CAN IDENTIFY YOUR
LINE. I DO NOT SHOW ANYONE OR
INVOLVEMENT. IN IN DO WE HAVE A
QUEUE FOR THOSE AND THOSE
OPPOSED MATTER MODERATOR. SURE
IN A FEW WAYS TO UPHOLD PLEASE
PRESS ONE TEN ZERO AGAIN IF YOU
CHOOSE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
AT THIS TIME. AT THE MOMENT
THERE IS NO ONE IN CUBA ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU DO OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN LONDON ZERO. WHAT WILL-GIVE IT A FEW MORE SECONDS-
YEAH AFTER. WE HEAR FROM ANYONE
WHO IS OPPOSED TO RELEASE TO
THEIR NAME AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
TO AT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I
SEE YES AS I SEE A- CENTER
NIELSEN DOES SO WE'LL TURN TO
YOU CENTER NIELSEN HERE IN JUST
A MOMENT. SO MADAM POTTERY OR
ANYONE ELSE- IN THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION. SURE AND AGAIN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU DO OPPOSE THE-
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
GERALD AGAIN IF YOU DO OPPOSED
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN KI<c.cyan> ALL RIGHT</c>
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MODERATOR AND THE CENTER
NIELSEN DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
COMMENT RIGHT HERE I'M- GO
AHEAD YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND FELLOW MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND STAINED
AUTHOR WHO I AGREE WITH ON MANY
THINGS ON THIS ONE WE VERY
VIGOROUSLY DISAGREE. I'M GOING
TO SPEAK FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT
HERE TODAY THE VICTIMS OF CRIME.
NOT JUST THE- SO CALLED LOW
LEVEL CRIME. AND I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. BURGER A SECOND LOW
LEVEL TRYING PROPERTY CRIME NO
BIG DEAL. WELL IT'S A LIFE
SENTENCE. AND PEOPLE WILL SAY
OH NO NO THAT'S YOU DON'T GET A
LICENSE SERVER VERY SECOND. NO
YOU DON'T. BUT THE VICTIM DOES
THINK OF THE MOTHER WHO'S
COMING HOME IN A DARKENED HOME.
THAT HAS BEEN BURGLED WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AT NIGHT. AND
EVERY TIME SHE DOES SHE LIVES
IN FEAR THAT THAT BURGER IS
GOING TO BE IN HER HOME.
FEARFUL OF WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. IN IT'S A MATTER OF NOT.
PREJUDICE HONEY OR DENYING A
RIGHT. IT IS ABOUT JUSTICE AND
HISTORICALLY PART OF JUSTICE
HAS REQUIRED THE FORFEITURE OF
VOTING. BECAUSE OF THE SEVERITY
OF THE IMPACT OF CRIME ON
SOCIETY AND ON INDIVIDUALS. AND
FOR INDIVIDUALS PROTECT PLAY OF
VIOLENT CRIME OF SEXUAL
OFFENSES THERE IS NO CLOSURE.
THEY LIVE WITH THAT ALL OF
THEIR LIVES AND HAVE THE
NIGHTMARES AND GREED EVERY
BIRTHDAY THAT COMES. BUT NOW WE
HAVE DONE A TREMENDOUS CHANGE
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. VERY FEW REALLY ARE
UNSUPERVISED ROLAND UNDER WHICH
YOU CAN JUST CALL CONDITIONAL
PAROLE AND THAT MEANS THERE ARE
CONDITIONS. AND EVEN GET NOW.
IN SOME AREAS WERE PAROLE DOES
YET EXIST. AN INDIVIDUAL BREAKS
THEIR CONDITION OF FOR THEY CAN
FACE CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING RE
INCARCERATION. WHAT COULD BE
THOSE CONSEQUENCES ONE WHO HAS
COMMITTED A VIOLENT CRIME. AND
STILL HAS POSSESSION. OF A
WEAPON. OR MANY WEAPONS. THAT
COULD GET THEM BUT BACK IN
CUSTODY. BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT NOW. IN
ADDITION WE'RE GOING TO REWARD
THEM. BY A RAPID RETURN TO
THEIR VOTING RIGHTS. SIMPLY
HAVING SERVED YOUR TIME IN
CUSTODY DOES NOT MEAN YOU HAVE
SERVED YOUR TIME. THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN UNTIL YOU ARE OFFICIALLY
DISCHARGED FROM PAROLE. AND
THAT'S THE TIME WHAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT FOR THE VICTIMS AND FOR
SOCIETY TO ENSURE THE JUST
DESSERTS. OUR ACCOMPLISHED. AND
THE TREND HERE TODAY. IS VERY
MUCH IN A DIFFERENT WAY. AND
I'M NOT SURPRISED THEY'RE NOT
LEGIONS OF VICTIMS CALLING IN
IN OPPOSITION. BECAUSE VICTIMS
OF CRIME SO DEMORALIZED NOW.
PHIL CUT OUT OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM FOR SUFFERING UNDER THE
AND JUSTICE THEY'VE GIVEN UP.
THEY NEED TO HAVE A FULL. A
VOICE. THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
COMMITTED THEIR CRIMES ONCE
THEY HAVE EXTINGUISHED THEIR
JUST DESSERTS. THEY CAN MOST OF
THEM. RETURN TO BEING VOTING
AND PARTICIPATING CITIZENS. BUT
THAT SAID I WILL SIMPLY. THANK
YOU SENATOR WILSON ANYONE ELSE
WISH TO COMMENT OR HAVE A
QUESTION- ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARTY OF- WELL
pCHAIR YOU KNOW THIS IS ABOUT
ONE OF THE MOST SACRED THINGS
THAT WE FOCUSED ON OUR
DEMOCRACY IN OUR GOVERNMENT
VOTING VOTING RIGHTS BUT THIS
IS ONE WHERE WE DON'T MAKE THE
CHOICE HERE TODAY. EVERY ONCE
IN AWHILE WE GO TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ASK THEM TO
WEIGH IN AND THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
BE DOING HERE THIS MORNING TO
AFTERNOON. YOU KNOW WE'RE ONE
OF THE FEW NATIONS IN THE WORLD
THEY RESTRICT BOATING RIGHTS
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THERE'S EVEN
ONE STATE IN OUR NATION WERE
YOU CAN VOTE FOR PRISON. WE'RE
NOT PROPOSING THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING WHAT. A BUNCH OF
STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE.
REPUBLICAN STATE AND DEMOCRATS
STATES. THIS IS. MARK FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY WE KNOW THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ROUTE. RE
INTEGRATED INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE MORE LIKELY. TO
DO WELL AND NOT- BACK TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THREE
NO IT'S GOOD FOR RECIDIVISM. WE
ALSO KNOW THIS IS MARK FOR
DEMOCRACY AS WELL EVERYBODY
SHOULD HAVE A VOICE. I WITH
THAT ASK YOUR IDOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. ALL RIGHT OF IS THERE
A MOTION. SENATOR LEYVA MOVES
SHE WAS HERE LONGER- X. SO OF
MISTER SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS STARTED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER HI NUMBER
HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG NAY LEYVA
LEYVA HI. STERN BY FOR LOTUS
FOR ONE ALL RIGHT THE MOTION
CARRIES THE MEASURE WILL BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- NO FURTHER
BUSINESS FOR THIS COMMITTEE WE
ARE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU ALL.